we're joined Now by retired Air Vice
Marshall Sean Bell and Sean first of all
why do we think this announcement has
been made today what about the timing
Jane yeah six months into the War I
think um the tide has turned and uh
President Putin's forces have been
having invaded have now been pushed back
the Russian army has been badly mauled
and is in a very poor State they
desperately need more people and as a
result they've tried bullying in
Mercenaries to try and bolster the
numbers they're relatively small numbers
and their Battlefield experience has not
been good they've fled as soon as
they've come under close contact so they
desperately need more shoulders soldiers
so they've looked at this partial
mobilization it's also the timing wise
that the U.N security Council is about
to meet and President Putin's always
used that as an opportunity for a bit of
saber rattling
and so what has been announced we're
looking at at the map the current area
with most of the fighting uh what what
difference is he hoping this is going to
make yeah the couple of things that um
one of which is the announcement of
referendums
um and we sort of expected that for some
time and they obviously did that and
Russia did that in Crimea first what
area is in the um the donbass region
here clinically that there is um they
don't the Russians do not own the whole
of the Don bass and actually if you're
going to run some sort of referendum you
actually need to be able to talk to the
people most of the people have fled that
area the only people in there are the
Russian separatists so it's very
difficult to see how you have a
meaningful referendum there if we look
across at the referendum for hessen and
across the zaparita very different uh
nature of the most the population is
still there but actually
um the the population of Harrison has
been very very resistant to the Russians
and it's almost impossible to see how
they would accept the Russians there so
in reality there would be no credible uh
referendum there the other thing that's
been announced is this uh mobilization
um in context when the Russians invaded
Ukraine they used about 190 000 uh
soldiers that's woefully inadequate from
a military perspective for a country to
invade a country of 44 million people
and the second largest country in the
world and it was pretty evident they
expected just to walk in and not have to
fight
um let's put that into context the
Russian army itself is only 280 000
strong they've also got another 40 000
which is the forty four hundred thousand
uh the Russian internal protection Force
so in context what defense minister
should go has just recently announced of
300 000 extra reservists is about 20 000
more than the regular army so it's not
an insignificant number it's the first
time that actually Russia's mobilized
since the second world war so that's
significant but in context 300 000 looks
a big number but in reality Russia could
draw on up to 2 million uh reservists
who've served within the military in the
last five years and actually if you went
even further any Russians who served in
the military at any time you're into 25
million so number is but from a military
perspective none of these people these
reservists are going to be current none
of them are going to be competent or
trained and the danger is the
battlefield is the wrong place to be
learning how to fight a war and it could
be very damaging and certainly the
Western analysts do not believe this
will significantly change the tide of
the war in Ukraine and the nuclear
threat which he reiterated today he's
blaming the West saying that they are
the ones threatening but he is the one
who's talking about it yeah we've got to
be very careful I think let's take the
context of this to start with first of
all Putin's plan hasn't worked his
battle armies mauled the hardliners at
home will not see failure as an option
and history suggests that when Russia's
Army has failed that sometimes their
enemies capitalize and actually invade
Russia itself so this is as much these
announcements much to counter domestic
issues as they are international there's
two parts to his announcement that we
need to break out one of which is he
talked about Russia having better
weapons than the West what he actually
means there I believe is talking about
Russia has deployed into Ukraine weapons
such as the Hypersonic missiles that is
that's shown here underneath the uh fast
yet that is something the West has
notched deployed into Ukraine it doesn't
mean we don't have them just haven't
used them no it just means we haven't
used them but the fact remains is that
the the Western weapons have proved the
critical Advantage for Ukraine so that
is a much a demonstration but turning to
the nuclear question any discussion on
nuclear weapons for anybody it's
unsettling but when you look at the
words that President Putin used nothing
has changed he talks about they would
only be used if the territorial
Integrity of Russia was compromised and
that is as much to a threat to the West
as it is to demonstrate to his own
domestic audience that whilst they may
not have been doing well on the
battlefield they are still incredibly
strong the challenge ultimately though
is Putin is in a corner and we need to
provide an off-ramp for him it feels
like the time for diplomacy is fast
arriving there'll be some horrible
compromises that would have to be made
but ultimately you need to find a way of
ending this war otherwise we end up the
grave risk that Putin's misadventure
becomes a global catastrophe Sean thanks
very much